replacement of time masters is an
enormous responsibility we're not dying
masters there's no rules
seducing the Queen of France she seduced
me kidnapping Stein I like he's a pig
may we entertain
no nemesis haha DC's legends of tomorrow
season premiere Thursday October 13th on
the CW
hey youtubers is Charlie new Legends
footage we got star girl we got
reverse-flash finally we're like this
much closer to TV Young Justice so let's
break it down you can almost see Jeff
John's smiling way in the distance from
his office in Burbank so what's going on
here is they're just showing you what
they're doing as they becomes the new
time masters everyone's going crazy
they're a bunch of time criminals like
they kind of teased that during season
one the reverse-flash is a good example
of a time criminal someone who has the
ability to travel through time and just
change things to suit his desires so
that's why they're going back to all
these different time periods because
people have gone back you know Legion of
Doom people have gone back and just
completely messed with the timeline so
you probably heard that they're doing
Justice Society star girl obviously is
somebody from the future of the Justice
Society where we see our man here like
the person that you Bart Thawne here is
fighting is the our main character that
came back at the end of season 1 and
said you sent me back in time you know
don't do the thing you're getting ready
to do because it ends in catastrophe so
he's from the not-too-distant future
we're against firestorm is a little bit
older they never really say exactly how
far in the future but it's just implied
that like what all these people are
still relatively young and that's where
characters like star girl and citizen
steel come from citizen steel was in the
last trailer he's the guy during season
two is gonna be learning about his
powers in present day right now like as
season 2 is picking up he learns that he
has power search to freak out and then
just kind of figures it out over the
course of the season so most of you have
read some version of a Justice Society
story know that they're kind of like the
precursor of the Justice League so it's
usually implied that there are a lot of
older members so when they go back into
the past you'll meet some people that
used to be Justice Society characters
like citizen Steel's father who's
commander steel so they'll have like the
multi-generational approach to the
Justice Society that you've seen in the
comics way more comic book II this
season if Legion of Doom didn't tip you
off speaking of which the known members
of the Legion of Doom going into the
season I'm gonna probably add members as
they go along but we've seen
reverse-flash you guys know about that
Captain Cold we don't know which time
period he's gonna show up and maybe in
present day Malcolm Merlyn and then in
the past damian darhk-- there will be
like a rut you're speaking of damian
darhk-- cuz i know a lot of people are
like isn't black Canary's supposed to
appear
she will appear sometime during the
season we don't really know how but it's
part of Sara's storyline
it sounds like based on the footage
we've seen and what they've talked about
either she's going to revenge kill
damian darhk-- just to get back at him
for laurel or she's going to outright
try and save laurel using time travel
but all we really know is that katie
cassidy will appear some time on the
show but she's a series regular now on
all four of the TV shows which includes
legends of tomorrow which means somehow
she'll have to show up I don't know if
they would bring her back using time
travel because they were so adamant
about Black Canary not coming back on
arrow they're like this canary is dead
like they built a statue to her in that
arrow trailer so if Black Canary is like
alive on legends of tomorrow at the end
of the season maybe she'll just fly
around on a Timeship or maybe she'll
stay dead you guys can let me know in
the comments though if this show is all
about time travel do you think they're
gonna use that as a backdoor to bring
Black Canary back or do you think it's
gonna be one of those flashpoint type
things where like she gets there and she
almost saves Laurel but then realizes
it's gonna create another flashpoint and
it's super selfish so she's not gonna do
it
Sara is way more impulsive than Barry so
I'll be interested to see how they
handle that this season because they
could totally go back and pluck Black
Canary out of time before she gets
killed but I don't think they would do
anything to completely undercut what
they did on arrow so I'm not expecting
them to walk back Black Canary dying
last season but there'll be all kinds of
Justice Society obsidian is coming on
Lance Henriksen is playing obsidian who
is the son of the Alan Scott Green
Lantern so we're like one season away
from Alan Scott Golden Age Green Lantern
but I don't know that they would ever be
able to do Green Lantern's on a TV show
that's still kind of up in the air but I
do have some thoughts about the Green
Lantern Corps movie but that's so far
off we have Deathstroke Justice League
Batman stuff happening so I'll talk
about that next so be sure to subscribe
to get that in congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner meatball sub you
just have the most awesome name ever so
you and a $20 Amazon gift card just be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so and get your
contact details and I almost forgot Greg
Berlin see the person who does almost
every single DC Comics TV show is now
selling a black lightning show around
two networks so when we learn a little
bit more about that when something
actually happens I'll do a video for it
but wherever it ends
that probably won't be the CW just
because they're already maxed out on
their schedule so I wouldn't expect it
to be connected to all these other shows
but I'll do a video on that when we
learn a little bit more about what's
going on so a whole bunch of comic book
stuff happening this week I'll try to
get through it as fast as possible while
you guys wait for that next video to
post you can click here to learn more
about what's going on with the flash
season 3 and you can click here for my
arrow season 5 trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight